et on avait vraiment un énorme service
de sécurité on avait retiré les
appareils photos à tout le monde il y a
pas de portable c'est très très vigilant
il y avait un listing il y avait des
cartons d'invitation
il y avait je pense je pense qu'il y
avait un service de 250 mecs de sécurité
vraiment il y avait des hélico qui
tournaient pour prendre des photos c'est
vraiment un truc considérable et donc la
soirée se passe il y a le repas de
mariage donc je sais pas combien il y a
de tables avec tout le PAF qui chantait
Thierry et chante et qui rit et donc je
me retourne et je vois une table très
importante je crois qu'il y a la table
il y avait Thomas Valentin je crois
qu'il y a loué et Étienne Mougeotte et
je vois deux blaireaux à la table je dis
mais c'est c'est qui c'est donc
forcément c'est peut-être un invité de
ma femme donc je demande à Flavie je dis
tu les connais non non je les connais
pas mon père tu déconnais non pas du
tout et en fait les deux mecs ils
avaient réussi à incruster la soirée
avec avec des appareils pour prendre des
photos pour enregistrer exact donc on
les a sortis très amicalement de la
la salle et on les amenés dehors et donc
là j'ai appelé j'ai appelé la police
forcément et comme j'étais je me sentais
vraiment en sécurité avec 250 mecs
autour de moi mais
forcément j'ai pris des appareils photos
que j'ai copieusement écrasé broyé un
coup de pied puis j'ai mis deux trois
droites comme ça pour pour rester pour
rester pour le sport voilà comme j'avais
comme risquez pas grand chose c'était
vraiment je vais les frapper
j'ai pu me la péter
mais le plus normalement c'est qu'en
fait les gars ce que j'ai fait
totalement étonné par la loi ah oui et
si on vous prend en photo si vous n'êtes
pas paradis et vous prenez l'appareil
photo il faut l'écraser c'est vous
pouvez pas le faire donc ils ont porté
plainte contre moi et j'étais condamné
absolument
braquer une banque tu vois ils se sont
incrustés un mariage c'est pas non plus
un délit que dramatique combien mais à
l'époque c'était pas très beaux
appareils photos hein ces [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
le mariage avant ou après le divorce ça
c'est ton problème c'est ça le mariage
non ça va coûter combien de condamner à
15000 balles et quand même pour avoir
cassé les appareils photos
il faut préciser que tu les avais viré
parce que tu as vendu l'exclusivité de
ton mariage à un média soit on a
jusqu'au bout alors alors
oui oui absolument
alors oui je l'avais vendu alors
pourquoi pourquoi parce que c'est
combien tu as vendu Benjamin alors je
l'ai déjà dit
écoutez
alors je l'ai vendu 950 000 francs
950 950
feu d'artifice les routes étaient
bloquées par les policiers
quoi 950000 boules c'est pareil parce
que tu l'as ouais maintenant ça c'est
l'équivalent en 2001950000 mariage tu as
tout mis dans le mariage et tout ce que
j'avais touché oui tu regrettes pas du
tout c'est vrai pas du tout
c'était une très belle soirée et j'ai un
regret comme j'avais interdit toutes les
photos etc en fait j'ai pas de adore des
photos de presse
j'aurais bien j'aurais bien aimé avoir
le film parce qu'on a quand même fait
monter sur scène
qui ont fait un sketch pour nous c'est
dommage en vidéo
voilà tu as eu des beaux cadeaux ou pas
ah ouais j'ai des super cadeau ah oui un
truc dingue c'est qu'en fait comme on
était très engué avec la presse people
donc on avait mis on avait déposé une
liste de mariage dans un une agence de
voyage et donc tous les jours on va y
arriver des cadeaux et c'était dans une
agence de voyage que des voyages en fait
c'est moi qui était offert les Antilles
c'est moi j'ai trouvé ça assez drôle et
le retour l'aller-retour Melun c'est moi
et en fait il y avait il y avait plein
de gens qui ont fait tout le monde a
fait des cadeaux et il y avait des très
très beaux cadeaux enfin des très beaux
dons parce que c'est en fait c'était
l'oseille et on voit on voit un don à
l'époque de 15000 euros
ou 1500
et je vois prisme ma presse et c'était
le magazine Voici je me souhaiter un
joyeux voyage de noces qui avait donné
15000 balles sur l'île de voyage j'ai
trouvé ça assez drôle de leur part du
coup on leur faisait des procès tous les
toutes les trois semaines
élégance c'est incroyable ton histoire
et quelle est l'invité qui a donné le
plus beau cadeau
je vais vous dire c'est je peux vous
dire qui c'est c'est Stéphane courby mon
ami voilà c'est amis
alors c'est vrai qu'il est toujours très
généreux
en tout cas moi Stéphane voilà bon tu
étais heureux tu es heureux très heureux
le voyage le divorce t'a coûté beaucoup
plus non mais divorce voilà
rien à manger